the world may be waking up to the fact
that intelligence will be automated
sooner than anyone could have imagined a
few years ago but it is still sleeping
when it comes to who gets the spoils
just today the Vice President of America
said the AI will never replace workers
and only boost productivity then again
Sam Alman CEO of open AI wrote just
yesterday that he could see labor losing
its power to Capital and Rand the famous
Think Tank put out a paper just the
other day that said that the world isn't
ready for the quote job losses and
societal unrest end quote that it thinks
might accompany a more General
artificial intelligence but even if
labor does lose Capital can't decide who
gets the money just today musk and Co
challenged Sam mman and Microsoft for
control of open AI itself and of course
there are always papers like this one
from Stanford suggesting that the
reasoning enhancements needed to bring a
model to Frontier capability are
achievable for just $20 which makes me
think you guys can afford AGI after all
meanwhile Dario amade CEO of anthropic
makers of Claude says that time is
running out to control the AGI itself I
just think that when the day inevitably
comes that we must confront the full
automation of intelligence I just hope
we are a little more unified let's say
than we are now there is too much to
cover as always so let's just cut it
down to the seven most interesting
developments using the samman essay as
the jumping off point for each first off
he gives his fifth or maybe 15th
different definition for AGI but this
time it's we mean it to be a system that
can tackle increasingly complex problems
at human level in many fields well under
that definition we are getting awfully
close take coding where we heard in
December that the O3 model was the 175th
highest ranked coder in code forces ELO
now that might not mean much to many
people but just yesterday in Japan
samman said they now have internally the
50th highest scoring competitor we're
clearly well beyond imitation learning
these systems 01 03 04 they're not
copying those top 50 competitors saying
coding they are trying things out
themselves and teaching themselves
through reinforcement learning what
works we are not capped at the human
level and that applies to way more than
just Cod
I've been using deep research from open
AI on the pro tier this week to at least
suggest diagnoses for a relative and a
doctor I know said that it found things
that she wouldn't have thought of of
course it does hallucinate fairly
frequently but it also thinks of things
you might not have thought of and
remember this is 03 searching maybe 20
sources what about 05 searching 500 and
you might say well knowing stuff is cool
but white color workers actually take
actions on their computers well Karina
nen from open AI has this to say on task
they're saturating all the benchmarks
and post chaining itself is not hitting
the wall basically we we went from like
raw data thoughts from from featuring
models to infinite amount of tasks that
you can teach the model in the post
chaining World via reinforcement
learning so any task for example like
how to search the web how to use the
computer how to write a well like all
sorts of tasks that you like trying to
teach the model all the different skills
and that's why we saying like there's
no data wall or whatever because there
will be infinite amount of tasks and
that's how the model becomes extremely
super intelligent and we are actually
getting saturated in all benchmarks so I
think the bottleneck is actually in
evaluations and there's a reason I can
believe that even though their current
operator system only available on Pro
for $200 a month is quite Jank it's
because tasks like buying something
online or filling out a spreadsheet are
mostly verifiable and whenever you hear
verifiable or checkable think ready to
be absolutely eaten by reinforcement
learning just like domains like code
where you can see the impact of enhanced
reinforcement learning from 01 preview
to 03 next is the investment that must
go in to make all of this happen and Sam
Alman had this to say later on in the
essay the scaling laws that predict
intelligence improvements have been
accurate over many orders of magnitude
give or take the intelligence of an AI
model roughly equals the log of the
resources used to train and run it so
think of that as kexing the resources
you put in to get one incremental step
forward in intelligence doesn't sound
super impressive until you read the
third point and I agree with this point
the socioeconomic value of linearly
increasing intelligence each increment
is super exponential in short if someone
could somehow double the intelligence of
03 it wouldn't be worth four times more
to me and I think to many people it
would be worth way way more than that it
would be super exponential he goes on a
consequence of this is that we see no
reason for the exponentially increasing
investment to stop in the near future in
other words if AI will always pay you
back tenfold for what you invest in it
why ever stop investing many forget this
but less than 2 years ago samman himself
said that his grind idea is that open AI
will capture much of the world's wealth
through the creation of AGI and then
redistribute it to the people we're
talking figures like not just a 100
billion but a trillion or even 100
trillion that's coming from him only
adds if AGI does create all that wealth
he's not sure how the company will
redistribute it to give you a sense of
scale as you head towards 100 trillion
you're talking about the scale of the
entire labor force of the planet and
that of course brings us to others who
don't want him to have that control or
maybe want that control for themselves
as you may have heard about Elon Musk
has bid almost 100 billion for open AI
or at least it's a bid for the nonprofit
which currently controls open aai to
save you reading half a dozen reports
essentially it looks like Sam wman and
open AI have valued that nonprofit stake
in open aai at around $40 billion that
leaves plenty of equity left for for
Microsoft and open aai itself including
its employees however if musk and others
have valued that stake at 100 billion
then it might be very difficult in court
for mman and Co to say it's worth only
40 billion so even if they reject as it
seems like they have done M offer it
forces them to potentially dilute the
stake owned by Microsoft and the
employees Alman said to the employees at
openai that these are just tax itics to
try and weaken us because we're making
great progress the nonprofit behind open
AI could also reject the offer because
it thinks that AGI wouldn't be safe in
the hands of musk at this point I just
can't resist doing a quick plug for a
mini documentary I released on my
patreon just yesterday it actually
covers the origin stories of Deep Mind
open AI the tussle with musk and
anthropic and how the founding vision of
each of those AGI Labs went arai this
time by the way I used used a
professional video editor and the early
reviews seem to be good all the
shenanigans that are going on with the
nonprofit at open aai seem worthy of an
entire video on their own so for now I'm
going to move on to the next Point
samman predicted that with the Advent of
AGI the price of many Goods will
eventually fall dramatically seems like
one way to assuage people who lose their
job or see their wages drop is that well
at least your TV is cheaper but he did
say the price of
luxury goods and land may rise even more
dramatically now I don't know what you
think but I live in London and the price
of land is already pretty dramatic so
who knows what it will be after AGI but
just on that luxury goods point I think
samman might have one particular luxury
good in mind yesterday in London samman
was asked about their Hardware device
designed in part by Johnny IV from Apple
and he said it's incredible it really is
I'm proud of it and it's just a year
away yes by the way I did apply to be at
that event but you had to have certain
org IDs which I didn't one thing that
might not be a luxury device are smaller
language models in leak audio of that
same event he apparently said well one
idea would be we put out 03 and then
open source 03 mini we put out 04 and
open source 04 Min he added this is not
a decision but Direct directionally you
could imagine us saying this take all of
that for what it is worth the next
jumping off point comes in the first
sentence actually of this essay which is
that the mission of open AI is to ensure
that AGI benefits all of humanity not
that they make AGI that they make an AGI
that benefits all of humanity now
originally when they were founded which
I covered in the documentary the charter
was that they make AGI that benefits all
of humanity unencumbered by the need for
a financial return but that last bit's
gone but we still have that it benefits
all of humanity not most of humanity by
the way benefits all of humanity I
really don't know how they are going to
achieve that when they themselves admit
that the vast majority of human labor
might soon become redundant even if they
somehow got implemented a benevolent
policy in the US to make sure that
everyone was looked after How Could You
ensure that for other nations after
watching Yoshua Benjo one of the
Godfathers of I and I'll show you the
clip in a second I did have this thought
it seems to me if a nation got to AGI or
superintelligence 1 month 3 months 6
months before another one it's not the
most likely that they would use that
advantage to just wipe out other nations
I think more likely would be to wipe out
the economies of other nations the US
might automate the economy of say China
or China the US and then take that
wealth and distribute it amongst its
people and yosua Benji thinks that that
might even apply at the level of
companies I can see from the
Declarations that are made and you know
what you know logically these people
would do is that the people who control
these uh systems like like say open AI
potentially um they're not going to
continue just selling the access to
their AI um they're going to give access
to you know a a a a lower gr AI they're
going to keep the really powerful ones
for themselves and they're going to
build companies that are to compete with
the Noni you know systems that exist and
they're going to basically Wipe Out the
economies of all the other countries
which don't have these system don't have
these super intelligence systems so it's
it's you you know you you say it's you
wrote It's not existential but I think
it is existential for uh countries who
don't build up to this kind of level of
um Ai and um it's it's an emergency
because it's going to take at least
several years even with with the a
coalition of the willing to to bridge
that and just very quickly I can't help
because he mentioned competitor
companies to mention Gemini 2 Pro and
Flash from Google new models from Google
Dem mind there's also of course Gemini
thinking which replicates the kind of
reasoning traces of say o03 mini or deep
seek R1 now straight off The Benchmark
results of these models are decent but
not stratospheric for the most part
we're not talking 03 or deep seek R1
levels on simple bench we're rate
limited but it seems like the scores of
both the thinking mode and Gemini 2 Pro
will gravitate around the same level as
the quote Gemini experimental 126 but I
will say this I know it's kind of Niche
Gemini is amazing at quickly reading
vast amounts of PDFs and other files no
its transcription accuracy of audio and
I've tested isn't going to be at the
level of say assembly Ai and no its
coding is no 03 and its quote deep
research button is no deep research but
the Gemini series are great at
extracting text from files and they are
incredibly cheap so I'm quite impressed
and I do suspect as chbt just recently
overtook Twitter to become the sixth
most visited site and slowly starts
closing in on Google that Google will
invest more and more and more to ensure
that Gemini 3 is state-of-the-art next
man wrote about a likely path that he
sees is AI being used by authoritarian
governments to control their population
through through Mass surveillance and
loss of autonomy and that remark brings
me to the Rand paper that for some
reason I read in full because they're
worried by not just Mass surveillance by
authoritarian dictatorships but other
threats to quote National Security
Wonder Weapons systemic shifts in power
kind of talked about that earlier with
say China automating the economy of the
US non-experts in powered to develop
weapons of mass destruction artificial
entities with agency think 06 kind of
coming alive and instability this is
Rand again which has been around for
over 75 years and is not known for
dramatic statements again I would ask
though that if the US does a quote large
National effort to ensure that they
obtain a decisive AI enabled wonder
weapon before China say 3 months before
6 months before then what are you really
going to use it to then disable the tech
sector of China for me the real
admission comes towards the end of this
paper where they say the US is is not
well positioned to realize the ambitious
economic benefits of AGI without
widespread unemployment and accompanying
societal unrest and I still remember the
days when ultman used to say in
interviews just around 2 years ago he
said stuff like if AGI produces the kind
of inequality that he thinks it will
people won't take it anymore let's now
though get to some signs that AGI might
not even be controlled by countries or
even companies for less than $50 worth
of compute time of course not counting
research time but for around apparently
$20 worth of compute time affordable for
all of you guys Stanford produced S1 now
yes of course they did utilize an
openweight base model quen 2.5 32
billion parameters instruct but the
headline is with just a th000 questions
worth of data they could bring that tiny
model to being competitive with 01 this
is in science gpq and competition level
Ma mathematics the key methodology was
well whenever the model wanted to stop
they forced it to continue by adding
waight literally the token waight
multiple times to the model's generation
when it tried to end imagine you sitting
an exam and every time you think you've
come to an answer and you're ready to
write it down a voice in your head says
wait that's kind of what happened until
the student or you had taken a set
amount of time on the problem
appropriately then this is called test
time scaling scaling up the amount of
tokens spent to answer each question
I've reviewed the questions by the way
in the math 500 Benchmark and they are
tough so to get 95% at least the hard
ones the level five ones are so to get
95% in that is impressive likewise of
course to get Beyond 60% in GP QA
Diamond which roughly matches the level
of phds in those domains to recap this
is an off-the-shelf open weights model
trained with just a thousand questions
and reasoning tra es there were some
famed professors in this Stanford team
and their goal by the way was to
replicate this chart on the right which
came in September from openai now we
kind of already know that the more
pre-training you do and posttraining
with reinforcement learning you do the
better the performance will be but what
about time taken to actually answer
questions test time compute that's the
chart they wanted to replicate going
back to the S1 paper they say despite
the large number of 01 replication
attempts none have openly replicated
ated a clear test time scaling behavior
and look how they have done so I'm going
to simplify their approach a little bit
because it's the finding that I'm more
interested in but essentially they
sourced 59,000 tough questions physics
olympiads astronomy competition level
mathematics and AGI eval I remember
covering that paper like almost 2 years
ago on this channel they got Gemini
thinking the one that outputs thinking
tokens like deep seek R1 does to
generate reasoning traces and answers
for each of those 59,000 examples now
they could have just trained on all of
those examples but that did not offer
substantial gains over just picking a
thousand of them just a thousand
examples in say your domain to get a
small model to be a true Reasoner then
of course get it to think for a while
with that weight trick how to filter
down from 59,000 examples to 1,000 by
the way first decontaminate you don't
want any questions that you're going to
use to then test the model of course
remove examples that rely on images that
aren't found in the question for example
and other formatting stuff but more
interestingly difficulty and diversity
this is the kind of diversity that even
JD Vance would get behind on difficulty
they got smaller models to try those
questions and if those smaller models
got the questions right they excluded
them they must be too easy on diversity
they wanted to cover as many topics as
possible from mathematics and science
for example they ended up with around 20
questions from 50 different domains they
then find tuned that base model on those
a thousand examples with the reasoning
traces from Gemini and if you're
wondering about deep seek R1 they
fine-tuned with 800,000 examples
actually you can see that in this chart
on the right here again it wasn't just
about fine-tuning each time the model
would try to stop they said wait
sometimes two four or six times to keep
boosting performance basically it forces
the model to check its own output and
see if it can improve it notice weight
is fairly neutral you're not telling the
model that it's wrong you're saying wait
maybe do we need to check that they also
tried scaling up majority voting or
self-consistency and it didn't quite
have the same slope suffice to say
though if anyone watching is in any
confusion getting these kind of scores
in GP QA Google proof question and
answer and competition level mathematics
it's insane incredibly impressive of
course if you took this same model and
tested it in a different domain it would
likely perform relatively poorly also
side note when they say open data they
mean those thousand examples that they
fine tune the base model on the actual
base model doesn't have open data so
it's not truly open data as in we don't
know everything that went into the base
model everything that quen 2.5 32
billion parameters was trained on
interestingly they would have gone
further but the actual context window of
the underlying language model constrains
it and karpathy in his excellent chat
gbt video this week talked about how
it's an open research question about how
to extend the context window suitably at
the frontier it's a 3 and 1 half hour
video but it's a definite recommend from
me actually speaking of Kathy his
reaction to this very paper was cute
idea reminds me of let's think step
by-step trick that's where you told the
model to think step by step so it spent
more tokens to reason first before
giving you an answer here by saying wait
we're forcing the model to think for
longer both lean he said on the language
prior to steer the thoughts and speaking
of spending your time well by watching a
Kathy video I would argue you can spend
your money pretty well by researching
which say charity to give to through
give well they are the sponsors of this
video but I've actually been using them
for I think 13 years they have
incredibly rigorous methodology backed
by 60,000 Plus hours of research each
year on which Charities save the most
lives essentially the one that I've gone
for for actually all of those 13 years
is the against malaria Foundation I
think started in the UK anyway do check
out givewell the links are in the
description and you can even put in
where you first heard of them so
obviously you could put say AI explained
but alas we are drawing to the end so
I've got one more point from the saman
essay that I wanted to get to in
previous essays he's talked about the
value of Labor going to zero now he just
talks about the balance of power between
capital and labor getting messed up but
interestingly he adds this may require
early intervention now openai have
funded studies into Ubi with let's say
mixed results so it's interesting he
doesn't specifically advocate for
Universal basic income he just talks
about early intervention then talks
about compute budgets and being open to
strange sounding ideas but I would say
if AGI is coming in 2 to 5 years then
the quote early intervention would have
to happen say now I must confess though
at this stage that I feel like we
desperately need preparation for what's
coming but it's quite hard to actually
specifically say what I'm advocating the
preparation be then we get renewed calls
just today from the CEO of anthropic
Dario amade about how AI will become a
country of geniuses in a data center
possibly by 2026 or 2027 and almost
certainly no later than 2030 he said
that governments are not doing enough to
hold the big AI labs to account and
measure risks and at the next
International Summit there was one just
this week we should not repeat this
missed opportunity these issues should
be at the top of the agenda the advance
of AI presents major new Global
challenges we must move faster and with
greater Clarity to confront them I mean
I'm and I think many of you are that
change is coming very rapidly and sooner
than the vast majority of people on the
planet think the question for me that
I'll have to reflect on is well what are
we going to do about it let me know what
you think in the comments but above all
thank you so much for watching to the
end and have a wonderful day